i'm having a little bit of an aha moment
right now because i realize
in that moment when things you know
weren't exactly as we think they're
supposed to be in society there's a
tendency
to run away from it or to find the fault
within
and i feel like what you and i are
sort of promoting is hook in to that
family
and choose to be together choose to stay
together
i just want to say can we go back and
say preach drew when you said hook
in that is the mantra that everyone
needs to take away right now
please welcome promo brown
i don't know where this music is taking
us
but i know we're dancing with it um
caramel i'm so happy
to be with you i've missed you i've been
thinking about
us and our whole revelation
and saying that both of us latched on to
like little magnets
yes we did it was magical i love when
those things happen
where you say something and we both feel
the power within the statement and how
it could help not only ourselves but
others
it was a good moment sometimes metaphors
feel like floating balloons to me
and hooking in feels the exact opposite
yeah agreed because sometimes you have
these statements or these mantras that
it's like
okay i don't know how to tangibly make
that work for my life
and this one it's like oh the first of
all like you just said the act of
hooking into something you know that
you're grabbing it you're attaining it
but then also you understand how that
could work mentally
as much as it works physically so it is
a very powerful mantra
i think it gives me like an anchor
metaphor of groundiness
but it also makes me feel like i'm going
to have to do the work
at the same time yes and that work is so
key because
without with any mantra or anything
you're using for your life
if you're not putting the work in with
it then you're not able to
hook into what you're really going after
and that's why this term hooking in
i think is going to be so powerful this
is this is the 2021 theme this is what
it is everyone listen
hook in because you deserve life you
deserve
all these things and this is step one
all right let's get into it caramel
i'm so excited let's take a look at
jacqueline roll the tape please
hi drew hi caramo my name's jacqueline
and i'm a single mom i've been in a
committed relationship
for several years now and up until this
point my partner and i have always lived
separately
so it's been several years now and
ultimately
my partner and i have decided to move in
together
we talked about it as a couple and then
we discussed it with
my son and everybody's excited and on
board so that will be happening in the
next few months
however there's a few issues that i'm
concerned about
one of which is that i have a teenage
boy
which i know every parent of teenager
understands it comes with its own
huge set of challenges that i feel like
i'm navigating through every day
one of the things i'm concerned about is
that my partner is very kind and very
passive
we love his energy when he comes to our
house but
he has up until this point really just
been more of a friend
to my son and i really am going to need
him to step up and do more of that
fatherly
role or disciplinary role and having my
back so that we are more of a unified
front together
to create some healthy boundaries for my
son so haramo and drew i would
really appreciate your help in
navigating this new family dynamic and
showing me any ways that we really hook
them
jacqueline please come on the show hello
hi guys how are you today
hi i have some questions
right out of the gate if i may ask what
are your
biggest concerns about bringing
john and tristan into the same house
up until now john has always been just
this great friend
to tristan and that's kind of been his
role
i would like for that role to develop
a little bit into more of um
a co-parent and a maybe even authority
figure
you know something where he had john has
a little bit more
um ownership of the co-parenting
jacqueline first of all i want to let
you know i understand exactly
what you're going through i have teenage
i have teenage boys they're now in their
20s
but when i was introducing them to my
partner and moving my partner in
it was one of these things of like okay
what is about to go on here
how are we going to make this a family
unit what are we going to do and i think
thinking about this theme of hooking in
the first thing i want you to ask
yourself
is do you believe john can hook into the
idea
that he is enough and can you hook into
the idea that he's enough
um the short answer is yes i think that
maybe i need to
kind of give him that permission
you're the person has to give that
permission once you give that permission
the three of you have to sit down and
establish clear boundaries
and i'm talking about you got to get
specific is john going to be
giving money is john going to be able to
set curfews
is john going to be the one to say when
to get in the shower when to get up for
school
is john going to be able to say you can
go to the park what permission and
boundaries does john has
but also don't put it all on john you
have to now look at your son and say
son with you in the boundaries what what
permission does he have
of what to say to john how should he be
referring to john in this new step
how he should should he be interacting
with you so when john's talking to you
before your son only had mom so he could
run up to mom and
get mom's attention there's now another
adult here so
how does he need to learn in that moment
of like mom and dad
mom and partner not to put you you know
rush you but mom and partner are
speaking
you need to now understand how to
approach this
there's a lot about giving permission
and clear boundaries that has to happen
here so that you can have the successful
relationship you want
[Music]